تغطتنا المباشره مشاهدينا متواصله لاثار
الزلزال العنيف والمدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا ووصلت تداعياته الى الشمال السوري
اعداد القتلى في ارتفاع مستمر فيما تتواصل
عمليات الانقاذ بحثا عن ناجين الزلزال
مشاهدينا بلغت قوته 7.8 درجات على مقياس
ريختر وافادت رويترز قبل قليل بان زلزالا
بقوه سبع درجات ونصف الدرجه ضرب وسط تركيا
فيما تحدثت قبل ذلك السلطات التركيه عن
انهيار 1700 مبنى في عشر ولايات تبقى
الارقام في سوريا مجهوله على الجانب
السوري ضرب زلزال المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها المعارضه والمكتظه بنحو اربعه
ملايين سوري نزحوا من مناطق اخرى من
البلاد
ولن اتابع هذه الاخبار العاجله الاسفل
الشاشه سكان العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت
شعروا فعلا بهزه ارتداديه اذا سكان
العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت يشعرون
بهزه ارتداديه على النظام السوري كان قد
تحدث عن زلزال جديد ضرب العاصمه دمشق
واللاذقيه ومحافظات
اخرى اذا والاتحاد الاوروبي كذلك يعلن عن
تفعيل القمر الصناعي الاوروبي لمسح
المناطق المنكوبه
اذا
في ذات السياق اكد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ان دمارا كبيرا خلفه زلزال اليوم
في عدد من المناطق مشيرا الى ان الاولويه
الان هي اعمال الانقاذ حيث يوجد تسعه الاف
عنصر ضمن فرق الانقاذ
تسبب في هدم واضرار في عدد من المحافظات
وسبب دمارا كبيرا المحافظات استنفرت كل
قوتها الى جانب المحافظات ادارات الولايات
لهذه المحافظات ومؤسساتنا التي تعنى
بالكوارث القوات المسلحه التركيه ايضا تم
توظيفها في تلك المناطق اولويتنا كانت ولا
زالت هي اعمال الانقاذ حاليا يوجد 9000
عنصر ضمن فرق الانقاذ وسيتزايد هذا العدد
اردوغان كذلك اعلن ارتفاع اعداد ضحايا
الزلزال الى 912 قتيلا واكثر من 5000 جريح
وفيما يتعلق بالمساعدات اكد الرئيس التركي
ان 45 دوله الى جانب النيتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي تشارك في اعمال الانقاذ لمواجهه
اثار الزلزال المدمري في تركيا
حاليا هناك كسوليه واثنا عشر مواطن توفي
وما زاد على خمسه الاف جريح
2800 مبنى هدمت بالكامل العديد من المباني
تضررت لا زالت عمليات الانقاذ مستمره لا
ندري الى اي مدى ستصل هذه الارقام وبشان
المساعدات الدوليه للتواصل مع الدول
الاخرى الى جانب ميتو والاتحاد الاوروبي
هناك 45 دوله قدمت طلبا لتساعدات هذه
الكارثه
قلعه غازي عنتاب التاريخيه التي تم بناؤها
منذ اكثر من
2200 عام الى الانهيار خلال الزلزال الذي
وقع في تركيا بحسب ما افادت بعض وسائل
الاعلام التركيه وحسب وسائل الاعلام
التركيه فان قلعه غازي عنتاب التاريخيه
تعرضت لاضرار جسيمه بسبب مركزها الذي
عرضها بشده للزلزال الذي جاء بقوه
7.7 درجات على مقياس ريخ ما لم يتم بعد
تحديد الاضرار التي لحقت بالحصن
وقعت انفجارات وحريق في قسمين من خط
انابيب للغاز في مدينه هاتاي التركيه جراء
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال
غرب سوريا ذكرت وكاله اخلاص التركيه
للانباء ان السلطات التركيه قررت تعليق
توريد الغاز الى عدد من المناطق الواقعه
بالقرب من بؤر الهزات الارضي
ونتحول الان الى السيد صخر النسور الباحث
المختص في علوم الارض والجيولوجيا سيد صخر
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه المباشره على
شاشه العربيه دعني ابدا معك من التغريد
الجدل التي غرد فيها احد الخبراء
الهولنديين احد خبراء الجيولوجيا كان
يتوقع منذ يومين او ثلاثه ايام حدوث مثل
هذا الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا لبنان ايضا
كذلك اضاف الاردن الى القائمه معظم هذه
الدول حدثت فيها بالفعل هذه الزلازل
والهزات الارتداديه اولا برايك ما سبب
يعني لماذا توصل الى الى هذا الاستنتاج في
هذه المنطقه
تحديدا وكذلك ايضا الشق الاخر من السؤال
ما الذي يجب على هذه الدول ان تفعله عندما
تعلم او عندما ياتيها انذار مبكر لحدوث اي
زلزال مشابه لما حدث اليوم
شكرا اخي الكريم اود ان اؤكد على جزئيه
مهمه في في مجال علمي اولا لم يتوصل العلم
لغايه هذه اللحظه بامكانيه التنبؤ في وقت
وشده ومكان حدوث الزلزال من المعروف ان
المنطقه التي تحدث اليها او تحدث عنها هي
منطقه زلزاليه تصنف منطقه زلزاليه تاريخيه
نتيجه القراءات التاريخيه للعرشيف لقاعده
البيانات الزنجاليه هذه منطقه تركيه ايران
القوقاز هذه منطقه معروف انها منطقه
الحدث في نهايه التسعينيات ان كانت قويه
لدرجه سبعه درجات على مقياس رخصه
يعني هذه
يعني هذه الزلازل تحدث يعني منذ صباح
اليوم هناك هزات ارتداديه والان هناك
اعلان عن عن عن زلازل جديده لا نتحدث عن
هزات ارتداديه نتحدث عن زلازل جديده في
دمشق كما قال اعلام النظام السوري في
اللاذقيه وغيرها قبل قليل ايضا حتى سكان
بيروت شعروا بهزه ارضيه والعراق ايضا
كردستان العراق له كوربيد
تفضل
بالحكمه وهي مناسبه من خلال شاشه كل
الكريمه ان نشير الى انسنه العالم وعلى
العالم
لان هذه الكوارث الطبيعيه بحاجه الى تكاتف
جماعي ودولي للمناطق المنكوبه وبالتالي
هذه الهزات لا تعرف الحدود نحن نتحدث عن
صفائح تتحرك وبينها طوالق كبيره صدور
رئيسيه كبيره هذه الصدوع في حال حركتها
يبدو ان الصفيحه العربيه اللي نحن موجودين
في منطقتنا موجودين عليها قد انزالقت
كثيرا في السنوات الماضيه باتجاه الشمال
وبالتالي اليوم يحدث
تكسير حاله تكسير
شديد ويولد طاقه كبيره في باطن الارض يتم
التعبير عنها من خلال الهدات الارضيه
والموجات الزلزاليه التي تخرج الى السطح
هذا التصادم بالصفائح معروف مثبت علميا
لذلك تجد ان هنالك احزمه معروفه بين
العراق وايران بين
افغانستان وباكستان والمناطق اليابان
تركيا هذه معروفه بان هنالك حركه الصفائح
تؤدي الى التصادم التساقط صفائح تص
ادم وبالتالي يعني نحن نحن موعودون يعني
لا سمح الله بزلازل جديده ذات ارضيه ايضا
جديده في هذه المناطق في القريب
ومستقبلاسف طردي
كتناسب طردي مع شده الزلزال الذي حدث فجر
اليوم قبل قليل
7.7 وهذا زلزال جديد ايضا حدث في جنوب
تركيا
من المتوقع من الطبيعي ان ينتج الذات
الاقتباديه وقد سجل لغايه هذه اللحظه اكثر
من 100
ارتداديه وصدقها كانت اعلى عشر زلازل كانت
شدتها بحدود
درجات على مقياس الاخضر وبالتالي نحن
نتحدث عن مزيد من الهداف الابتدائيه اين
سيكون النطاق الجغرافي يعني ابعد نطاق
جغرافي متوقع علميا سيد صخر لما حدث اليوم
اليوم اليوم نحن بحدود في عمان مثلا 600
كيلو متر عن منطقه بولس الزلزال شعرنا
فجرا بهزه خفيفه يعني
بعض السكان مناطق المملكه الهاشميه شعروا
بهذه الهزه في مصر وشعروا في هذه في سوريا
سوريا ولبنان اقرب الى البؤله جداريه من
موقع
وبالتالي قبرص واليونان ايضا هذه مناطق
مؤخره ما اود ان اشير له انه انه الوقت
وقت حدوث الزلزال ويزيد في عدد الضحايا
ورقم اثنين
نشاهد على فضائيات بحدود والمواقع الابنيه
التي حجز جزء كبير من هذه الابنيه غير
مصممه
مخصصه لمقاومه الز
يرتفع للاسف يعني عدد الضحايا وتوقفها ان
عدسه فجرا من الناس لازال في منازلهم ايضا
يزيد عدد الضحايا طيب سيد صخر ابقى معي
ساعود اليك مره اخرى في خضرا طبعا هذه
التغطيه المعهد القومي مشاهدينا للبحوث
الفلكيه قال ان الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
فجر اليوم
وتاثرت بها شمال سوريا بشده حدث في منطقه
نشطه زلزاليه وانه من الطبيعي حدوث زلزال
فيها بتلك القوه الزلزال وقع في الساعه
الواحده وسبعه عشره دقيقه بتوقيت بتوقيت
جرينتش اي في الساعه الرابعه وسبعه عشره
دقيقه فجرا بتوقيت تركيا قوته على مقياس
ريختار بلغت 7.7 درجات وقدر عمقه ب
18.30 كيلو متر بخط عرض بلغ سبعه
عشر شمالا وخط الطول بلغ
18.30 شرقا اكثر المدن مشاهدينا تضررا
جراء هذا الزلزال العنيف في تركيا هي غازي
عنتاب وديار بكر واضن ولطيه بينما كانت
اكثر مدن ومحافظات سوريا المتضرره الواقعه
شمالا هي اعزاز واللاذقيه وحماه وحلب
وطرطوس كما امتد اثر الزلزال ليشمل لبنان
والاردن وكذلك العراق
مباشره الى مراسل العربيه من اسطنبول
زيدان زين كلو زيدان مرحبا بك معي في هذه
النشره من جديد قبل قليل رويتر ساتحدث عن
زلزال او هز ارتداديه ضربت وسط
تركيا هل من معلومات او تفاصيل لديك جديده
نعم بحسب التلفزيون الرسمي التركي هو
زلزال جديد ضرب نفس المنطقه التي ضربها
الزلزال الاول لكن منطقه قريبه في ولايه
كهرمان مرعش هذه المره في منطقه غوزبينار
في ولايه كهرمان مرعش زلزال جديد بقوه 7.6
على مقياس
7.6 درجات على مقياس ريختر قبل حوالي ساعه
من الان او اقل من ساعه على حسب او بالضبط
قبل ساعه من الان في هذه المنطقه
ليزيد اليزيد من المتاعب التي تواجه فرق
الانقاذ اذا
زلزالان في نفس المنطقه في ولايه كهرمان
مرعاش كهرمان مرعش كلا الزلزالان بقوه
تجاوزت 7.6 خلال ساعات قليله فقط او تفصل
بين
توقيت الزلزلين
اذا هذا كما ذكرت سيزيد من المعاناه طبعا
نتيجه هذا الزلزال وصل صدى الزلزال او
تاثير الزلزال ايضا الى ولايه غازي عنتاب
كما تحدثنا قبل قليل
العشرات بل الالاف من الاهالي الذين كانوا
يختبرون في عده مناطق خرجوا الى الشوارع
خوفا من هذا الزلزال والهزات الارتداديه
التي ستليه حتى الان منذ الصباح وحتى
اليوم اكثر من 110 هزات ارتداديه ضربت عشر
ولايات تركيا هي الولايات الجنوبيه في
تركيا وهي التي تضررت من الزلزال الاول
ولا نعلم حتى الان الانباء عن مدى الضرر
الذي خلفه الزلزال الثاني لذلك نتوقع او
السلطات تتوقع الاسوء وتامل ان تصل فرق
الانقاذ بسرعه الى اماكن الاماكن المتضرره
الرئيس التركي كان يتحدث عن اكثر من تسعه
عن اكثر من 9000 شخص
من فرق العنقاد يواصلون العمل
للوصول الى الانقاذ وانقاذ العالقين تحت
الانقاض لكن يامل الرئيس التركي والسلطات
التركيه في حال تم
استكمال وصول فرق الانقاذ وطواقم الانقاذ
الى المواقع المدمره بتكثيف عمليات البحث
والوصول الى ناجين اكثر وبالتالي تخفيف
من وطاه هذه هذه الكارثه على تركيا طبعا
الرئيس التركي قال انها الاسوا منذ عام
1939 وهذا يعني انها اكبر بكثير من زلزال
اسطنبول عام 1999 حيث ضرب الزلزال منطقه
بحر مرمره وعلى وجه التحديد
منطقتي ازمه واسطنبول وخلف 17 الف ضحيه
اليوم نتحدث عن زلزال ضرب عشر مناطق تركيا
الزلزال الاول الزلزال الثاني حتى الان لا
نعرف سوى انه تاثرت مدينه غازي عنتاب ايضا
بهذا الزلزال وايضا سكان انقره شعره بهذا
الزلزال ومسافه كبيره بين انقره وكرمان
مرعش نتحدث هنا عن الزلزال الثاني وايضا
في بعض المناطق في البحر الاسود تحديدا
ولايه سامسونج قال السكان انهم شعروا
بالهزه الارضيه او الزلزال الذي ضرب
كهرمان مرعش قبل حوالي ساعه من الان هل
هناك مناطق يعني شعرت بهذه الهزات
الارتداديه زيدان في خارج هذه الولايات
العشره النما الى علمك هذه
يعني اي انباء من هذا القبيل او ربما
قراته على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي لاننا
بصراحه كل
في لحظه بلحظه تخرج باخبار من مناطق
مختلفه مدير مختلفه دول مختلفه ايضا كذلك
زيدان
نعم انا اتحدث هنا عن تركيا المناطق خارج
الولايات العشره تحدثت عن انقره العاصمه
انقره وايضا عن ولايه سامسون البعيده جدا
في الشمال على البحر الاسود ايضا سكان هذه
الولايه شعروا او احسوا بالزلزال الثاني
في ولايه كهرمان مرعش قبل حوالي ساعه من
الان لذلك هو زلزال قوي لا شك الولايه
ولايه كهرمان مرعش ضربت في زلزالين شديدين
يتجاوز كل منهما 7.5 خلال ساعات قصيره فقط
لذلك حتى الان الجهود يعني الظروف الجويه
نتحدث صراحه وكما تشاهد ويشاهد الساده
المشاهدون هذه الظروف السيئه سواء هنا في
اسطنبول او في انقره او حتى في المناطق
المنكوبه عواصف وثلوج في كل المناطق
تقريبا ودرجه حراره متدنيه جدا تحدثنا مع
عائلات في غازي عنتاب قبل قليل خرجوا الى
الشوارع هائمين لا يوجد لباس للاطفال اي
لباس احتياطي للاطفال
عشرات الالاف هون في الشوارع حتى الان
السلطات تحاول تامين الماوى لكن الاعداد
كبيره نتحدث عن عشر ولايات في نفس الوقت
تضررت وبالتالي نتحدث عن عشرات الالاف بل
مئات الالاف من السكان نزلوا الى الشوارع
يعني هو تحدي كبير جدا امام السلطات
التركيه التي طلبت المساعده
التي طلبت المساعده من الدول
انا اعتذر صراحه
يعني ان البرد قارص جدا والاحوال الجويه
يعني ربما تزيد من وطنه الامر زيدان شكرا
جزيلا لك ساعدك تجمع بعض المعلومات ربما
وكذلك
لاي تحديثات ومعلومات جديده سنتابع معك
اولا باول مع زيدان زنكلو مراسل العربيه
من اسطنبول الذي اشكره حتى اللحظه الى
القامشلي من هناك مراسل العربيه جمعه كاش
جمعه مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه حتى
الان ضحايا الزلزال الارقام تتحدث عن
710 قتله الى الان في سوريا هل هذه حصيله
نهائيه او الحديث ايضا عن ارتفاع عدد
الضحايا الى 371 قتيلا في حلب وحماه
اللاذقيه وطرطوس هل من تحديثات جديده لديك
الارقام الرسميه تتحدث عن 221
قتيل بينما في مناطق سرط نظام تتحدث عن
قتيل اي نحن امام احصائيه تقول بان هناك
592 شخص فقدوا حياتهم في هذه في هذا في
هذا الزلزال بينما اعداد الاصابات فهي
بالتاكيد
بالالاف المناطق الاكثر تضررا هي حلب فقط
يعني حتى نكون يعني دقيقين في الارقام 571
شخص في كافه المدن والمناطق السوريه
592 شخص في عموم سوريا 221 في مناطق سيطره
المعارضه السوريه
371 في مناطق سيطره النظام لانه نتحدث عن
قرابه 600 شخص فقدوا حياتهم في هذا
الزلزال اعداد الاصابات بالالاف لا يمكن
احصائها لان اعمال البحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاض لا تزال مستمره وفق معلوماتنا
المؤكده تم انتشار حوالي خمسين شخص من
منطقه سرمدا والاتارب في ريف حلب
الشمالي وايضا في ادلب الشمالي خلال
الساعه الساعات القليله
الماضيه بينما لا يزال عشرات العائلات
والاشخاص تحت الانقاض لم تصل اليهم فرق
الدفاع المدني ولا حتى الجهود يعني جهود
الاهالي لانتشالهم من تحت ركاب المنازل
طيب فرق الانقاذ دعنا نتحدث عنها بشكل
اكبر
الجمعه هل هناك عدد كافي يوازي هذه
القوه في الزلزال يوازي ايضا الكم الهائل
من المباني التي دمرت من الانقاذ التي
التي يعني نتابع صورها الان ربما يعني على
شاشه العربيه ومنذ الصباح ام هناك نقص
ونقص كبير تحتاج هذه المناطق الى زياده في
اعداد المنقذين وكذلك ايضا حتى وضع في
الطاقه الاستعابيه في المستشفيات في هذه
المناطق جمعه المساحه الجغرافيه التي
شملها الزلزال مساحه واسعه وكبيره وهي
اصلا مناطق شهدت حرب طوال العقد الماضي
وبالتالي البنيه الخدميه والبنيه الاغاثيه
وحتى البنيه الصحيه متداعيه وغير كافيه
للتعامل مع مثل هذه الكارثه التي اسفلت عن
مئات القتلى والاف الجرحى وهي منا متداخله
من حيث السيطره والنفوز العسكري للمعارضه
للنظام وكان القطاع الطبي يعني يحتل يعني
مراكز متاخره من حيث السلم الاولويات
بالنسبه للجهات الحاكمه في هذه المناطق
لذلك القطاع الطبي يعاني بشكل كارثي في
هذه الاوقات صور التي وردتنا المصابين
الذين ذهبوا خلال الساعتين الماضيه
الماضيهتين لم يستوعبها مما المركزي وايضا
لم يصعفهم مشفى عفرين العسكري وبعض منهم
تم يعني معالجته على ارصفه المشفى وفي
كاليدورات المشفى لا توجد اسئله ولا يوجد
طاقم طبي كافي كمال لا يوجد ادويه كافيه
لان معظم الاصابات كما كنت قد قلت هي
اصابات في في العظام في عظام الجسم وفي
عظام الجمجمه اجهزه الر المغناطيسي غير
متوفره اما على الجانب الاخر الجانب
انتشار الضحايا السكان فرق الدفاع المدني
بعض الفصائل العسكريه
على جانب المعارضه كل هؤلاء يحاولون يعني
انقاص حياه ما يمكن انقاذه بينما على جانب
النظام البلديات بعض الاهالي الجيش السوري
ايضا
هيئه وزاره الصحه الهلال الاحمر العربي
السوري كل هؤلاء يحاولون ما بامكانهم
لانقاذ
يعني عشرات الناس العالقين في مباني مهدمه
في مدينه جبله وفي مدينه طرطوس وفي مدينه
بني ياس اي في عموم الساحل السوري
طيب اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات ابقى معي او سنتركك ايضا لبعض
الوقت حتى تجمع بعض المعلومات ربما
الجديده من حولك او ايضا بعض التحديثات
فيما يخص فرق الانقاذ وايضا المباني التي
دمرت محاوله يعني معرفه تفاصيل ادق لحظه
بلحظه شكرا جزيلا لك جمعه عكاش مراسل
العربيه من القامشلي سنعود اليك في خضم
هذه النشره الهند مشاهدينا تعلن الان
ارسال مساعدات طبيه الى تركيا في اعقابي
هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا صبيحه
هذا اليوم على مقياس سبعه فاصله ثمان
درجات على مقياس ريختر كذلك المرصد السوري
تحدث قبل قليل عن ارتفاع اعداد ضحايا
الزلزال في سوريا الى 700
وعشرين قتيلا من الحدود السوريه التركيه
ابراهيم
الادلبي الصحفي ابراهيم مرحبا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه ابراهيم يعني ربما تابعنا
الاوضاع في الولايات التركيه التي تضررت
جراء هذا الزلزال وجراء ايضا تداعيات
الهزات الارضيه وقبل قليل ايضا مع زميل
الجمعه عكاش في الشرق السوري
الاوضاع في الحدود السوريه التركيه حتى
هذه اللحظه كيف تبدو اعمال الانقاذ ايضا
كيف تبدو ما الذي رصدته اهلا وسهلا بك
وبجميع المشاهدين اعمال لانقاذ ما تزال
مستمره منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر بعد
البلاغات التي بل اقام المدنيون بالابلاغ
عن مواقع المتضرره في مدينه الاثارب التي
كان لها النصيب الاكبر من عمليه الانهيار
والقتل من المدنيين حيث وصل الى 70 شخص
لقوا حتفهم جراء العمليات طبعا الرقم
للاسف مرجح للزياده لان عمليات البحث عن
ناجين تحت الانقاذ ما تزال مستمره وايضا
عمليات الاحصاء الصعبه جدا في ظل الموجات
متكرره للخروج خارج المناطق السكنيه
باتجاه الاراضي الزراعيه او باتجاه الحدود
السوريه التركيه باتجاه المخيمات عنهم
يجدون قليل من الدفا للاطفال في الخيام
التي فتح ناجحوها ابوابهم
من اجل دخول المدنيين الذين نجحوا من
المناطق السكنيه من سرمدا والمناطق
القريبه
بالبقاء بسرمدا حيث كانت هناك عمليات
انقاذ للمدنين بعد الزلزال الثانيه الذي
ضرب منذ قرابه الاربعين دقيقه منطقه سرمدا
وادى الى انهيار مباني جديده المدنيين
تطوعوا مع فرق الدفاع المدني والمنظمات
الانسانيه والمختصين لمحاوله انقاذ
المدنيين الذين كانوا عالقين منذ ساعات
الصباح المبكره او في محاوله لاخراج جثث
المدنيين القتلى تحت الانقاذ ايضا في
مدينه جرابلس بريف حلب بعد زلزال الثاني
الذي حدث والذي كانت قوته بحسب المصادر
المطلعه 7.5 اداء لانهيار عدد من المباني
ولكن الحمد لله كانت خاليه لم يوجد فيها
عدد من السكان منذ قليل كنت اتحدث عن
مناشدات للتوجه باتجاه المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه من جبل عفوا المنطقه الغربيه من
جبل الزاويه بسبب صعوبه الظروف الجويه
وعدم قدره الدفاع المدني لانه يعمل بط
القصوى والمدنيه بالتوجه الى بعض القرى
التي تضررت جراء عمليه الزلزال منذ قليل
وردت معلومات ان عدد من التركسات والاليات
العسكريه خرجت من نقاط المراقبه الموجوده
على طريق الام فور والنقاط المراقبه
التركيه من اجل محاوله الوصول الى هؤلاء
المدنيين العالقين على المنطقه الغربيه من
جبل الزاويه ببعض القرى ككفر عويد وايضا
منطقه عين لاروز اضافه الى المناطق
المحاديه بالجسر الشغور ايضا بالحديث عن
الوضع الطبي يتحدث مراسلكم عن العمل الطبي
بالطاقه القصوى وفاق الطاقه القصوى حقيقه
نعم طبعا
وانت معي على الهواء اعتذر على المقاطع
ولكن نشاهد هذه الصور
لعمليات الانقاذ
للمتضررين جراء هذا الزلزال نشاهدها الان
محاوله يعني اخراج هذه
السيده التي يعني علقت في
حد المباني التي نشاهدها الان في الصوره
وخلف هذه الرافعه هذا المبنى الذي تضرر
جراء الزلازل والهزات الارتداديه التي
ضربت تركيا صباح هذا اليوم وفرق الانقاذ
التركيه تبدو الان ما منعلى الصوره وهي
تنتشر طبعا هذه
السيده في منطقه اضنه التركيه والتي تعرضت
ايضا الى الزلزال صباح هذا اليوم كانت من
المناطق التي تعرضت لهذا الزلزال وكذلك
ايضا تضررت بالهزات الارتداديه تم انقاذ
هذه السيده الان محاوله تهدئه هذه السيده
التخفيف من وطئه الامر يعني
وشده طبعا الحدث
الاعمال الاعمال الانقاذ تتواصل في اضنه
كما تتواصل ايضا في الولايات التركيه
الاخرى وكذلك ايضا في السوريه التي نقلها
لنا قبل قليل جماعه عكاش الصوره من هناك
اذا هذه السيده التي تم انقاذها من احد
ربما المباني التي انهارت او سقطت بشكل
جزئي في منطقه اضنه التركيه جراء الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا صباح اليوم وكانت قوته 7.8
درجات على مقياس ريختر اذا هذه البنايه
التي تعرضت ربما بشكل جزئي
طبعا للتلف بعد هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه من تركيا وكانت هذه احد
العمليات ايضا عمليه الانقاذ ربما لا يزال
هناك بعض العالقين نتابع في الصوره
الاشخاص الموجودين في هذه البنايه البنايه
التي تضررت بشكل
جزئي من
جرار طبعا الزلزاله ضربات ايضا حتى
ارتداديه كنا قد تابعنا قبل قليل عمليه
انقاذ السيده كانت تقطن هذه
البنايه
نعيد التذكير فقط بضحايا هذا الزلزال حتى
الان 720 قتيلا في سوريا و912 قتيلا في
تركيا حتى الان هذا حسب الارقام التركيه
حسب الرئيسه التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اذا
هنا شبكه
كردستان العراق تعلن ايقاف تصدير النفط
عبر تركيا نتيجه الزلازل اذا كردستان
العراق تعلن ايقاف تصدير النفط عبر تركيا
نتيجه
للزلازل
والهند ايضا كانت قد اعلنت ارسال مساعدات
طبيه الى تركيا في اعقاب الزلزال الذي حدث
صباح هذا اليوم والان الاباء تشير الى ان
كردستان العراق قد اوقف نقل طبعا
او تصدير انك عبر تركيا نتيجه
للزلازل اعود مره اخرى الى السيد ابراهيم
الادلبي سيد ابراهيم يعني ربما توقفنا بعض
الشيء لمتابعه هذه المشاهد
من عمليات الانقاذ التي تتواصل في كافه
الولايات والمناطق التي ضربها الزلزال احد
هذه المناطق هي منطقه اضنه كنت تتحدث عن
الوضع في الحدود السوريه التركيه انا اريد
السؤال كذلك عن عن الطقس الى الطقس البارد
والثلوج ايضا كذلك اعاقت وصول يعني
المنقذين وايضا كذلك المسعفين الى مناطق
التضرر في الحدود السوريه التركيه جراء
هذا الزلزال تفضل نعم صحيح كانت العاصفه
الثلجيه متزامنه او مترافقه مع لحظه بدايه
الزلزال الذي ضرب فجر اليوم ثم اتحول
الطقس لتصبح عاصفه مطريه وهذا ما خفف نوعا
ما عمليه الفتح الشوارع ولتصبح سالكه
بالنسبه لسيارات الاسعاف وحتى بالنسبه
للسيارات المدنيه التي تساهم بعمليه نقل
المصابين بعض المناطق التي كنت قد تحدثت
عنها بوقت سابق الموجوده في منطقه جبل
الزاويه وايضا بريف جسر الشغور شوارعها
كانت مغلقه بسبب ان الحركه المدنيه في تلك
المنطقه هي اقل من حركه الشمال باتجاه
الحدود السوريه التركيه كانت تركيز على
فتح الطرق المؤديه الى الحدود السوريه
التركيه والقرى والبلدات القريبه بعمق كما
تحدثت قرابه 30 كيلو او حتى في ريف حلب
ريف حلب الشمالي بذات العمق الى مدينه
الباب كان هناك مساهمه من القوى العسكريه
وزاره الدفاع التي ارسلت العديد من
الاليات التي كانت تستخدمها في وقت سابق
على خطوط الجبهات لعمليه فتح الطرق حاله
انسانيه فيما ايضا وردتنا كما تحدثت قبل
انقطاع المداخله عن تحرك بعض من الاليات
التي كانت تستخدمها القوات التركيه بنقاط
المراقبه على
باتجاه منطقه جبل الزاويه والريف الغربي
من محافظه ادلب من اجل محاوله انتشار
الناس من تحت الانقاض كنت اتحدث ايضا عن
صعوبه الوضع
الطقوس الجويه التي اعاقت في مرحله ما
وصول المدنيين او حركه المدنيين المصابين
باتجاه النقاط الطبيه ولكن بالعمل الدؤوب
لدى الجميع الان هناك حاله من الطرق هناك
طرق تسلكها هذه السيارات للوصول الى
النقاط الطبيه والى المشفى العسكري بعفرين
الذي اصبح الان هو مركز الثقل والذي يكتظ
باعداد كبيره جدا من المصابين الذين يتم
استخراجهم من ريف جنديرس اي ريف عفرين ومن
ريف ادلب ايضا هناك قسم ينقل الى منطقه
عفرين الى المشفى العسكري اما الحالات
الحرجه فهي تنقل الى اراضي التركيه من اجل
تلقي العلاج هناك على مستوى الان المدنيون
ما زالوا متواجدين او جل المدنيين
متواجدين في العراء منهم من اتجه اتجاه
الحدود السوريات تركيا
ومنهم من فضل البقاء ضمن التجمعات
العشوائيه خارج المناطق السكنيه المهدده
بالهنيار بعد المناشدات الكبيره التي تم
اطلاقها من الصباح الباكر بوجوب خروج
المدنيين باتجاه الاراضي الزراعيه
والابتعاد عن المباني الجميع كان بالمرحله
الاولى متردد من عمليه الخروج بسبب الظروف
الجويه الصعبه ولكن بعد بعد العديد من
الرداد الاهتزازيه خرج الجميع باتجاه لا
اشمل الجميع يكون واضحا الجميع لا يعني
الجميع خرج من يستطيع الخروج باتجاه
الاراضي الزراعيه ومنهم من بقي بملاجئ
داخل المناطق كانتحدث عن المدارس او حتى
كانت اقويه تستخدم بوقت سابق للاختبار من
القصف الجوي ولكن المعلوم والملاجئ سيد
ابراهيم يعني مجهزه بشكل كافي لحمايه
السكان لحمايه من لجا اليها من يعني اي
هزات ارتداديه القادمه لا قدر الله او اي
حتى ايضا سلازل جديده وشكل جديد من هذه
الزلازل هذا ما نتمناه وندعي الله ان تكون
هذه الملاجئ على قدر الاستيعاب والطاقه
ولكن هي غير مجهزه هذه المراجعه كانت
تستخدم للاختباء من القصف الجوي فقط اما
بالنسبه للهزات الارضيه او بنيه تحتيه
مجهزه
لهكذا حالات لم يكن في المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه من سوريا لان هذه المره الاولى
التي تتعرض فيها هذه المنطقه لهذا النوع
من الهزات على مرور طيب على يعني هذه
المعلومات دعني انتقل فيها الى السيد صخر
النسور وهو
الباحث في علوم الارض والجيولوجيا سيد صخر
مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى اريد ان ابدا معك
ممن مما انتهى به السيد ابراهيم قبل قليل
هذه هي المره الاولى التي ربما يضرب فيها
الحدود السوريه التركيه في مناطق يعني
عفرين وما حولها هل من تفسير علمي لحدوث
هذه
منازل لاول مره بهذا الشكل في هذه المنطقه
نعم اخي الكريم القراءات التاريخيه تشير
الى ان الزلازل المدمره الكبيره
[موسيقى]
تحتاج الى فترات طويليه زمنيه طويله يعني
هي متباعده حكما ستكون متباعده ويبدو
انذار ضرب جنوب تركيا في نهايه التسعينيات
وبالتالي مره تقريبا 24 عام على اخر كبير
ومدمر ما اود ان اشير له انه في هذه
الفتره من السبات عن الزلازل ربما ان حركه
الصفيحه قد انزلقت كثيرا وولدت طاقه
مختزنه في باطن الارض تم التعبير عنها
اليوم في فجره في زلزال الكبير
7.7 ثم تلاهوا قبل ساعه تقريبا زلزال اخر
بسبعه ونص وهذا مدعى الى زياده الهزات
الارتداديه اكثر فاكثر التي سنلمسها في
الوقت
اللاحق ايضا القرين على مدى الاسابيع
والاشهر القادمه ولكن ستخف تدريجيا
رئيس مرصد الزلازل في تركيا وايضا ايضا
حتى الخبير الذي تحدثت عنه معك في بدايه
هذه التغطيه الخبير الهولندي الذي كان قد
تنبا بهذا الزلزال يتحدثون بان هذا
الزلزال ربما ينذر بخطر تسونامي في
المحافظات الساحليه وتحدث الى الرئيس مرصد
الزلزال في تركيا بانهم اخطروا 14 دوله
بذلك اولا هل خطر تسونامي خطر حقيقي خطر
مرجح بعد هذه الزلازل كيف تقراه سيد صخره
انت
لازم تولد عواصف تسونامي وتاريخيا معروفه
عالميا حدث ذلك ولكن حسب مطالعتي للاخبار
بعض الدول خففت من حده الانذار في موضوع
حدوث الموجات تسونامي
كاطاليا مثلا خاصه من حده التاخذ لحدوث
تسونامي من المحتمل ان يحدث
سلامي لا ادري مدى قربه من السواحل
الشاطئيه النشاطات بعض المدن
قربه الزلزال ولكن من المحتمل ان يحدث ذلك
عالميا وكما اسلمت بان زلازل عابره للحدود
لا تعرف الحدود وبالتالي من المتوقع كما
طالعنا ايضا محطه فضائيته قبل قليل ان
دمشق تعرضت
وشمال العراق شعروا ايضا في هزات ارتداديه
حصلت وبالتالي من المتوقع ان
الليله غدا خلال هذا الاسبوع
ساعود معك للحديث عن الارتدادات وامكانيه
يعني
التزايد هذه الهزات الارتداديه لكن دعنا
نبقى في موضوع خطر تسونامي انت تقول بانك
بانه من المرجح لكن هل هو ترجيح كبير هل
هو متوسط ام هي يعني توقعات
علميه قد لا تكون دقيقه مئه في المئه لكن
علميا يحدث هكذا عندما تحدث زلازل بهذا
الشكل وارتدادات بهذا الشكل فانه يعقوبها
تسونامي اذا كانت مناطق ساحليه
نعم
التوقع كانت المناطق قريبه من الساحليه
فاحتمال يحدث موجات تسونامي ولكنها
لا ترتقي الى درجه
تحذير
يعني ابقى معي نشاهد الان عمليه
انقاذ ان كنت تشاهد الشاشه الان معنا هذه
عمليه انقاذ اخرى في احد المباني التي
تعرضت الى انهيار جزئي في
اضنه التركيه بعد ان شاهدنا انقاذ السيده
قبل قليل الان عمليات الانقاذ
مستمره في هذا الحي وفي هذه البنايه التي
تعرضت طبعا لانهيار جزئي وهي طبعا واحده
من البنايات التي تضررت كان نائب الرئيس
التركي يتحدث اليوم عن انهيار 1700 مبنى
في تركيا جراء هذا الزلزال الان احد هذه
الابنيه التي انهارت بشكل جزئي وربما يعني
تحطمت بشكل كبير هناك من ينتظر المساعده
ايضا هناك من ينتظر ان يتم انقاذه من هذه
البنايه المعرضه طبعا للسقوط بعد ان
انهارت بشكل جزئي وبعد ان دمرت يعني بشكل
كبير كما نشاهد الان واياكم على شاشه هذه
العربيه هذه الصور المباشره التي ننقلها
لكم من اضنه التركيه هو محاوله انقاذ طبعا
بعض العالقين في احد الابنيه المتضرره
جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا صباح اليوم
وسوريا قوته بلغت 7.8 درجات على مقياس
ريفتر الان حد احدى العمليات عمليات
الانقاذ نشاهدها على الهواء مباشره امامكم
بعد ان تم انقاذ السيده اخرى قبل قليل
وانزالها من هذه البنايه
محاوله اخرى اذا
انقاذ ما تبقى من العالقين داخل هذا
المبنى امامنا الان على شاشه العربيه فرق
الانقاذ في اضنه التركيه اذن هذه السيده
يتم انقاذها كذلك هي من علقت في
المبنى الذي انهار بشكل
جزئي الموقف كان طبعا موقفا صعبا كما
نشاهد الان ولم يكن على الاقل يعني متوقعا
حدوثه بهذا الشكل اذا تم انقاذ هذه السيده
وانزالها كذلك من احد البنايات التي تضررت
وانهارت بشكل جزئي في اضناب التركيه اعود
لك سيد صخر مره اخرى
وكنت تتحدث قبل قليل عن خطر
اذا الهزات الارتداديه ذكرت بان هناك اكثر
من 100 ارتداديه ومن اللافت ايضا حتى قبل
قليل
يعني ربما تابعت معي في الاخبار العاجله
اسفل الشاشه
بان المعهد الجيولوجي الدنماركي قال بان
سكان جرينلاند شعروا بالهزات الناجمه عن
زلزال تركيا يبدو ان جغرافيه هذا الزلزال
وارتداد هذا الزلزال تتسع شيئا فشيئا
نعم بمناسبه الحديث عن البنايات يعني يبدو
غياب الشمولي في موضوع كودات البناء وخاصه
للمناطق المصنفه يبدو انه في كثير من
المناطق لم يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار وبالتالي
تقليل واحده من ادوات تقليل الخسائر هذه
الكودات لتصوير الابنيه والمنشات الكبيره
بان تكون مقاومه للزلازل كحد يعني من من
الخسائر في الارواح البشريه وبالتالي ما
نشاهده يبدو انه هذا لم يؤخذ في عين
الاعتبار ولا في عين الحسبان موضوع
الكودات البناء المقاومه للزلازل هي مع
انه معروف ان مره اخرى ان هذه المناطق
نشطه زلزاليه نعيد تاكيد بان يبدو ان
مساحه
الهدات الاقتباديه في اتساع
ويشعب فيها مناطق كثر في العالم على
امتداد هذا العالم
ولا ادري فاتني ان اتابع موضوع عنق
الزلزال الثاني احنا علمنا ان الزلزال اول
كان عمقه عشره كيلو متر وبالتالي كلما زاد
العمق كلما ازداد نطاق تاثر المناطق
الابعد في في الهزاز يعني دعني اقول فقط
انقل لك عن المعهد القومي للبحوث الفلكيه
في تركيا قال بان قوه هذا الزلزال بلغت
سبعه فاصله سبعه درجات على مقياس ريختر
وقدر عمقه ب
18.30 كيلومتر وبخط عرض ايضا بلغه
37.13 شمالا وخط الطول بلغ
18.30 شرق الاعلى كانت هذه هي المعلومه
التي تبحث عنها سيد صخر
على عمق عشره كيلو متر نحن الان نتحدث على
عمق 18 كيلو متر وهذا يؤدي الى يعني
اتساء جغرافيه ومساحه التاثر او الحدوء
الشغل في الهزات الارضيه
ان كان الزلزال ضحلا وقريبا من تاثيره على
المناطق المجاوره يكون اكبر اكثر تدميرا
ويقل كلما كان العمق اكثر وبالتالي العمق
الاكثر يشير الى جزئيه اتساع جغرافيته
والشعور في الهزه الارضيه كلما ارتفع عمقه
اكثر وبالتالي
30 كم يعني وعلى حسب ايضا جغرافيه المناطق
التي تاثرت بهذا الزلزال سواء بالزلزال
نفسه ام ايضا بالهزات الارتداديه هل هذا
يعني تقدير صحيح في رايك سيد صخر
نعم وهذا مدعى الى ان تكتشر الموجات
الزلزاليه في باطن الارض لماذا اكبر كلما
ازداد العمق الى تنتشر الى مدى ابحث
يبدو ان ظاهره يعني
خطيره وفعلا المناطق ستكون منقوبه واعتقد
يعني نسال الله السلامه للجميع
وهي مناسبه من خلالكم لدعوه العالم الى
الانسنه والابتعاد لو اقتربنا كثيرا من
التسلح بالعلم بعيدا عن التسلح بالاسلحه
لعمل اجهزه انذار مبكر لتكثيف الابحاث
والدراسات العلميه لدراسه هذه الظاهره
للحد من المخاطره نحن لا نستطيع ان نوقف
الزلزال ولكن باستطاع الحد من المخاطر
الزلزاليه على العالم ان يتوجه لانشاء
مراكز البحوث علميه متقدمه وتكثيف البحث
حول هذه الظاهره الطبيعيه التي يعني تسبب
الالات الضحايا في كل عام على مختلف بقاع
العالم والابتعاد
يعني نبذ الخلافات والتوجه نحو السنه
العالم وهي مناسبه لابسه من خلال فضائيه
العربيه الكريمه يعني يختم معك بهذا
السؤال ربما تابعته في السنوات الاخيره
وربما هذا العام تحديدا تغير كبير في
المناخ في شكل المناخ في نشاطات المناخ
على مستوى العالم ليس فقط منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بل حتى التغيرات المناخيه في
اوروبا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم
نسمع يوما بدرجه حراره 78 تحت الصفر لم
نسمع كذلك ايضا او نرى او نشاهد ايضا
درجات حراره بعض المدن الاوروبيه مثل لندن
تفوق 42 درجه مئويه وحتى هنا في منطقه
الخليج ربما كان النشاط المناخي لاستمرار
هطول مياه الامطار او حتى احيانا لبعض
النشاطات الغباريه والترابيه يعني تعتقد
بان او حتى ايضا هطول الامطار في فصل
الصيف بان ظواهر مناخيه ليست طبيعيه او
ربما تكون جديده هل ما حدث اليوم من شكل
للزلازل في تركيا في سوريا في لبنان في
الاردن وفي كردستان العراق والان نتحدث
كذلك عن
الدنمارك وسكان جرينلاند هل هو جزء من هذا
التغير المناخي الذي يشهده العالم
قولا واحدا هنالك تغير وبدانا نشعر
بالاثار المترتبه على التغير المناخي كما
اسلفت في مقدمته ونحن متاثرين ولسنا
مؤثرين في هذا التغير المناخي في المنطقه
في منطقتنا وبالتالي
السبب الرئيسي معروف لدينا في تصادم صفائح
والحركات التكوينيه قد تكون ان كانت
التغييرات المناخيه لها
دور في ما يحدث ستكون نسبه قضائيه جدا
مساهمته لان السبب الرئيس معروف بسبب
تصادم الصفائح والحركات التكتونيه التي
تحصل داخل باطن الارض التغيرات المناخيه
جلها فوق سطح الارض ونحن نتحدث عن حركات
في داخل الارض من حركه صدور وتصادم صفائح
وتكسر صخور وتشكل طاقه هائله يتم التعبير
عنها بتفريغ تدريج او مره واحده كما حدث
للطاقه الهائله للمختزل في باطن الارض
المتوقع ان يكون وان كانت فتكون نسبه
مساهمه ضعيفه للتغيرات المناخيه ولكن مره
اخرى ومن خلالكم هذه التغيرات المناخيه
اصبحت ايضا توحد العالم باتجاه دراستها
لان الجميع سيتاثر فيها سواء بالفيضانات
والهيارات او بالجفاف وموجات الجفاف
الحاصله وتغير الهطول المطري والسلوك
المطري على مدى المعروف لدينا على مدى
اعوام في منطقتنا العربيه اصبحنا نشهد في
مناطق لم تشهد في الصلاه وهذا مدعى الى
مره اخرى الى دراسه هذه الظاهره اشكرك
جزيل الشكر السيد صقر النسور الباحثه
المختص في علوم الارض والجيولوجيه
السيد ابراهيم الادلبي الذي يشاركني هذه
التغطيه من الحدود السوريه التركيه السيد
ابراهيم مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى الحديث
الان عن امتداد اثر هذه الزلازل عن زياده
ايضا حتى الارتدادات كما ذكر السيد صقر
النسور قبل قليل بانها مرشحه هذه الهزات
الارتداديه للعوده مره اخرى وبان هذا
النشاط الزلزالي
سيستمر ايضا
يعني سيستمر ايضا
بنشاطه منذ صباح اليوم كما منذ صباح اليوم
متى اخر هزه ارضيه او ارتداد ارضي شعرتم
به في الحدود السوريه التركيه كانت اخر
هزه ارضيه منذ ما يقارب الساعه وعشر دقائق
في تمام الساعه الواحده و28 دقيقه كان
هناك هذا بحسب الوكالات الرسميه
بما يقارب 7.5 على مقياس رختر كان مركزها
كهرمان وصلت الى المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه
من سوريا وصولا بحلب وسوريا العاصمه دمشق
وكما اضافت من مصادركم شعر بها كل من كان
بالعاصمه بيروت
بلبنان ولكن نبقى بحديثنا عن المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه التي تفتقد للمقومات
والتخوفات من ردات اهتزازيه مستمره حيث
بلغ حتى الان الرداد الاهتزازيه بحسب
المصادر الرسميه 87 رد اهتزازيه منذ بدايه
الهزه الاولى في ساعات الصباح المبكر من
اليوم المدنيون لا يزالوا يتخوفون من
الردات الاهتزازيه بسبب عدم امكانيه
الصمود البناء المتواجد شمال غرب سوريا
والابنيه المتعبه والمنهكه جراء الحرب
اضافه الى دعني اقولها ان الان اصبحت اكثر
المناطق امنه امنه الزلازل والردات
الاهتزازيه هي منطقه المخيمات الموجوده
على الحدود السوريه التركيه صحيح انها
قريبه من مركز الزلزال الاول والزلزال
الثاني هو ان الردات الاهتزازيه فيها اي
ردات مرتفعه ولكن ستكون اقل ضررا على
المدنيين في حال سقطت الخيمه لا سمح الله
او حتى كان هناك هزه قد تصل الى اكثر من
سبعه على مقياس نختار سيكون الموضوع اكثر
امانا لهم اضافه الى التجمعات العشوائيه
التي بدات تظهر حقيقه على اطراف الطرق في
المناطق المؤديه للحدود السوريه التركيه
ان كان
باتجاه مدينه حارم او حتى على محيط مدينه
سرمدا والقرى المحيطه بها اضافه الى مدينه
اعزاز ومدينه عفرين التي اليوم المشفى
العسكري في مدينه عفرين يقوم باستقطاب او
باحتواء الحالات التي تصل اليهم من الريف
عفرين وعظام الريف مدينه حلب والباب هؤلاء
التجمعات هناك ما تزال المناشدات حتى هذه
اللحظه الى جميع المدنيين الذين ما زالوا
ضمن الابنيه السكنيه ولا يساهمون بعمليه
الانقاذ مع الدفاع المدني او فقط موجودين
من اجل الاهتمام من الظروف الجويه
مشاهدات الجميع بالخروج خارج هذه المناطق
السكنيه وزها باتجاه العراء وما يعرف لدى
الجميع بالمناطق الزراعيه بالرغم من قساوه
الجو ولكن عدد جميع انحاول الاحتفاظ او
الحفاظ على حياه البقيه من خلال التكاثر
وهذا ما شاهدته المنطقه حقيقه اصبحوا
اليوم كلهم على قلب واحد ويد واحده عندما
بدا الدفاع المدني بامكانياته المحدوده
بالانتشار التطوع البدنيون بشكل مباشر
لعمليه الانتشار واصبحوهم جزء من عمليه
التواصل والابلاغ عن الكوارث المتواجده او
حتى عن الناس المتواجدين تحت على الانقاص
في عيون المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من
سوريا من خلال التواصل السريع وحتى
المراكز التي تم انشاءها على عجل من قبل
المنظمات والدفاع المدني والحكومه
الموجوده الجميع الان يساهم بتخفيف هذه
المعاناه وكما اعيد واكرر ان المنطقه
الاكثر امانا هي الحدود السوريه التركيه
التي
تنتشر فيها المخيمات على طول هذا الحدود
يعني هذه المنطقه هي المنطقه الاكثر امانا
حتى هذه اللحظه لكن ماذا عن الطاقه
الاستيعابيه
للمستشفيات هناك
بالنسبه للفرق الانقاذ المحليه ايضا او
فرق المسعفين ايضا
لمن تضرروا جراء هذا الزلزال او لمن لا
زالوا حتى هذه اللحظه تحت الانقاب كيف
يمكن تقييم هذا الموقف تحديدا وهذا الاطار
سيد ابراهيم دعني ابدا من حيث انتهيت وهو
المشفى العسكري في مدينه عفرين والذي كان
عليه الثقل الاكبر من منظومه الاسعاف
السريع والدفاع المدني وعمليات النقل
للجرحى من جنديرس الذي هي كانت ثاني اكثر
مدينه متضرره غرب سوريا بعد الاتارب بريف
حلب وايضا هناك سيارات نقلت المصابين من
الاتاري باتجاه هذا المشفى والنقاط
المنتشره على طول الطريق ولكن المشفى اعلن
بمرحله عدم امكانياتي على الحاله او وصوله
الى ذروه الحاله الاستيعابيه داخل المشفى
مما مضطرهم الى وضع المصابين بارقه او
بكاليدورات المشفى ومنهم من تلقى
الاسعافات الاوليه بسيارته على باب المشفى
وبسياره التي كانت تقول له الى المنطق الى
المشفى من اجل تلقي العلاج بالانتقال الى
عقربات ايضا هناك مشفى مستشفى اعلن عن
وصوله الى ذروه الحاله الاستيعابيه وايضا
مشفى باب الهوى على الحدود السوريه
التركيه يقوم بتقديم المصابين النقاط
الطبيه المنتشره ما بين سرمدا ووصولا الى
منطقه سراقب للسيطره عليها قوات النظام
ايضا قامت باستيعاب عدد من المصابين ولكن
الحالات الحرجه تم نقلها الى الاراضي
التركيه من اجل تلقي العلاج في المشافي
والمدن التي تعرضت للزلزال للتحدث عن
انطاكيا بالنسبه لادلب اتحدث عن غازي
عنتاب وريفها بالنسبه لمدينه حلبها خطين
النقد بالنسبه للمصابين ذو الحالات الحرجه
التي
الافاد او حتى الهلال الاحمر التركي
المصابين على الحدود ويتم نقلهم بشكل
مباشر الى المستشفيات عبر حواله طبيه
اضافه الى كان هناك بعض المناشرات او
البلاغات من داخل المشفى التي نادت التي
دعت بعض المصابين الذين تم معالجتهم الى
مغادره المشفى من اجل افسح المجال لمصاب
اخر او لشخص تم انقذه من تحت على انقاذ
لنقله وتلقي العلاج جزء من المدنيين الذين
تلقوا الاسعافات الاوليه
خرجوا خارج المشرب اتجاه الاراضي الزراعيه
وباتجاه تجمعات الخيام بحثا عن قليل من
الدفن في هذه الظروف القاسيه على المستوى
الجوي اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات وعلى مشاركه هذه التغطيه الخاصه
والمباشره على شاشه العربيه السيد ابراهيم
الادلبي الصحفي من الحدود السوريه التركيه
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام لا زلنا نتابع واياكم
على شاشه العربيه نواصل معكم بشكل
تغطيه تداعيات هذا الزلزال وايضا الهزات
الارتداديه التي شعر بها سكان دول تركيا
سوريا العراق والاردن وايضا متابعه لهذه
الصور صور محاولات الانقاذ انقاذ من علقوا
تحت المباني التي انهارت بسبب هذا الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا صباح اليوم بقوه
7.8 درجات على مقياس ريختر قبل قليل
الطوارئ التركيه كانت تقول بالالم خاطر من
حدوث موجات تسونامي في السواحل المطله على
البحر المتوسط حتى الان وفي اخر الاحصائيه
ضحايا الزلزال 720 قتيلا في سوريا و912
قتيلا في تركيا حتى هذه اللحظه التغطيه
متواصله مستمره وبشكل مباشر على شاشه
العربيه مع زميله فاطمه فهد بعد قليل على
راس الساعه في رعايه الله